[Applause]
the celebration came swiftly for justin
trudeau on election day
you are sending us back to work
with a clear mandate to get canada
through this pandemic and to the
brighter days ahead and my friends
that's exactly what we are ready to do
moments before the victory speech the
canadian prime minister's key rival in
the election campaign conservative
leader aaron o'toole threw some barbs
and i told him if he thinks he can
threaten canadians with another election
in 18 months the conservative party will
be ready
the rumblings of an expensive election
only to be almost exactly where the
liberals were on august 15th when it was
called by the prime minister will
continue as will questions about the
future of both leaders
but on election night the mood was very
optimistic even sounding as though a
majority had been secured
i hear you when you say that you just
want to get back to the things you love
not worry about this pandemic
or about an election
that you just want to know that your
members of parliament of all stripes
will have your back through this crisis
and beyond
and certainly his supporters were very
happy with the win majority or not we
did a lot of hard work and like it paid
off so we didn't expect this result but
yeah it's better like to be on the top
the country finally has gotten a
progressive government that is going to
make sure
that canadians stay safe
and that we move forward for everyone so
many unknowns so much unexpected
certainly a stressful campaign for
canadians from coast to coast to coast
it's over justin trudeau is again prime
minister of canada jody vance al jazeera
montreal